the one the only Oprah
[Applause]
Winfrey he made it happen
we made it happen we made it
happen thank
you all
right and this is this this is Douglas
hi Douglas like my Sadie takes up space
loves it knows you belong here and all
of you shouting no disturbance to
Douglas he's been here since we started
filming in the pandemic and no one could
come to the show there was no audience
Skeleton Crew what was that
like well it certainly wasn't the vision
it wasn't the vision this is hard to do
every day it looks like it's the most
fun and it is the most fun and I know
that you feel that way because that
comes through you love your audience the
way I love my audience I could see that
you feel for your audience and that's
the reason you show up every but this is
really really really hard let me just
say when I when I did my very first show
for am Chicago back in
1984 there was no audience I had
accepted the job but never asked is
there an audience and I'd come from
Baltimore where I had an audience and I
walked in the first day there was no
audience I was like I'm not going to
survive without an audience and so we
would go out on the street and ask
people to come in to get warm in Chicago
you want free coffee and to watch the
show so there's like 14 chairs in the
audience so I never missed a day in 25
years because I knew that people were
coming from all over the country to that
show and if you came with your cousins
and your aunts and your girlfriends you
didn't want to hear opra sick you didn't
want to hear that so I would come in
sick and then people say go home take
care of yourself but I'm sure glad you
came because of the love for the
audience you do it for the audience we
do it for
you so soothing I want somebody to do
this for me all the time all the time
this is good something I um yeah I'm
available I can do it um something that
I learned about you because I I didn't
know this detail was that you would
spend time with the audience outside of
the show you were filming and one thing
that I've done is spend time with the
audience every day and I had felt guilty
for it no no no no no no it is necessary
and it's okay that it takes extra time
my crew used to be like oh my God how
much time is she going to spend talking
to that audience okay by the way I
promise would you please let the
audience go so we can get the next
audience
in
every day every day oh my God no sitting
with the audience you are the human
thought bubble of all the crew here
which we've launched with no no but
that's why this is so hard to do without
an audience and I was complimenting you
on the fact that you got through it
without an audience cuz it's almost
because you're not getting their energy
it's their energy it's their feedback
it's understanding whether whatever
you're saying is connecting look at lady
in red see she's nodding she's like the
amen choir so to do it without anybody
Applause to you Applause to you Applause
to
[Music]
you